[Musique]
la villa protocolaire du département de
la réunion a servi de cadre à la remise
des médailles du travail aux agents du
département
211 médaille d'argent pour 20 ans de
service soit 109 de vermeil pour 30 ans
et 26 d'or pour 35 ans ainsi trois cent
soixante personnes ont été récompensées
pour leurs actions et en ces tristes
sires distance s'il vous plaît je vous
avez à vous lever
nous allons servait une minute de
silence en hommage à madame paulette à
doivent la conscience
merci beaucoup merci vraiment que la
fois un moment solennel et un moment de
vous les qualités solennel parce que
dans la république
des cernes à une décoration à 9 ans ça
correspond à quelque chose
depuis 1945 cette médaille pau-nord
l'engagement au travail et au premier
rang accompagnés de leurs familles et
collègues
ils savent ce que cela signifie en six
ans on atteint la ligne d'arrivée j'ai
côtoyé plusieurs types de personnel de
personnes
j'ai appris beaucoup à leur contact
beaucoup d'expérience professionnelle
mais aussi un enrichissement au niveau
des collègues comme j'ai fait moi trois
quatre services et là je boucle un peu
la boucle si on peut dire je reviens
ladeira j'ai commencé à deraa et là je
reviens des rats show de 35 ans de
service là on est récompensé de ce qu'on
a fait du travail qu'on a
apportez donc oui c'est vrai c'est un
honneur une maison départementale de la
maison de tous les réunionnais je tiens
à vous voir
une fois n'est pas coutume les médailles
d'or sont passés en premier
un moment d'émotion pour les élus et
leur direction ce que nous vivons dans
un monde difficile et chaque jour nos
services sociaux et travailleurs sociaux
ceux qui sont en contact avec la
population quotidiennement mais voir les
difficultés de nos familles de nos
jeunes de nos gramounes de nos personnes
âgées et il appartient bien sûr au
département de leur donner les
meilleures conditions de travail et je
sais que parfois on va dire que les
reste encore beaucoup à faire et c'est
pour ça que nous sommes là la
collectivité compte 200 métiers pour
plus de 5000 agents qui rendent chaque
jour aux concitoyens le service au
public
[Musique]